como informábamos se dice que xiomara
castró es la más votada en la historia
de honduras pero esto sería contando a
partir del año 1981 verdad cuéntenos
hasta ese año cuál fue el recorrido
político en honduras
bueno muchas gracias santiago por la
invitación en efecto ésta es nuestra
onceava elección consecutiva
desde que honduras regresó a la
democracia no habíamos tenido una se
puede decir una participación tan masiva
en la historia reciente y eso se debe en
gran parte a la sed de cambio que hay en
el país acordémonos de que el partido
nacional el partido que ha estado en el
poder por 12 años muy manchado por
corrupción involucramiento del
narcotráfico e incrementó la pobreza en
el país en 10 puntos porcentuales
con una impunidad bárbara y la población
especialmente el voto joven que
representa el 50 por ciento del padrón
electoral
acudió en masa a pesar de la campaña de
desinformación y la polarización que
había previo a la jornada electoral
la población dejó el miedo en la casa y
se abarcó a la sala urna votó
masivamente y bueno no solamente es el
voto duro del partido libertad y
refundación acordémonos que hizo una
alianza con salvador nasralá que es
también una celebrity de en honduras que
jala mucho voto especialmente el voto
independiente indeciso y bueno este es
una elección
sin parangón no dejó una buena marca en
la historia del país en la cual el
clientelismo puede ser vencido se puede
comprar y se puede regalar comida pero
no se puede comprar la dignidad de la
gente no yo creo que eso es muy
importante y un mensaje claro para
obviamente este nuevo gobierno que se va
a formar también no nos queda poco
tiempo pero considera usted que xiomara
castró podría estar a la altura de los
desafíos como la violencia y la pobreza
en el país
bueno también depende en gran medida de
cómo se conforma el congreso nacional
creo que según nuestros cálculos del 50
por ciento del congreso se va a renovar
va a haber una curva de aprendizaje muy
corta hay muchas expectativas por
xiomara y esperemos que en estos
próximos 100 días pueda producir
resultados
que tengan impacto en toda su periodo
presidencial entonces hay mucho
optimismo hay muchas expectativas de
cambio creo que por ser también en la
primera dama la primera vez que tenemos
una presidente en honduras eso también
va a generar mucha participación
involucramiento de la mujer en espacios
de toma de decisiones yo creo que eso
también es un mensaje del cambio que se
está produciendo en honduras